a good evening and welcome I'm Linda
freed and I have the honor of serving as
the Dean of this amazing mailman school
of public health and the real honor of
introducing the graduating class of 2013
of the mailman School Department of
Health Policy and management's executive
mph program congratulations this is an
amazing class they're all amazing but
this one is really fabulous and it's a
class as all of your cheer cheering
squad knows of accomplished mid-to-upper
career healthcare professionals who have
done the unthinkable to set their
aspirations even higher than they were
in order to come back to school for 24
months in order to go back out and
change the world in ways that we need
that's an aspiration we all would want
people to do because this is a moment as
we'll hear from our speaker shortly of
such profound changes which this class
knows better than anybody right now such
profound changes in the health system
the health care delivery system the
public health system and we have I think
there is no better prepared class of
senior leaders and for a health system
of the future than this one to have the
kind of background that you have
acquired the deep knowledge the ability
to analyze the issues were confronted
with to have the skills and the ability
to parse systems and to lead them is a
combination in anchored in the values
and goals of securing the health of a
population that we need now and into the
future I'm confident knowing the faculty
up here and all the
faculty in this program that not only
have they been deeply invested in your
personal success but they are anchoring
it to the directions that we need for
health leadership of the future so
congratulations to all of you and I know
that given the full voice of the
cheering squad behind you that you have
been deeply cheered along the way by
many people who have made it possible
for you to be so successful in this
program and to have reached this point
so it's most appropriate to invite you
to turn around and for all of us to
thank your cheering squad behind you for
helping you get here
so for for our audience gathered here
today to celebrate these fabulous
accomplishments and these extraordinary
people I'll just tell you for a moment
about this class of 31 the average age
is 44 ranging from thirty to sixty two
years so really amateur group of leaders
already who made personal commitments to
lead at an even higher level the thirty
two percent of them already were
physicians fifteen percent an MBA nine
percent word dds six percent a JD and
six percent a PhD so an extraordinarily
accomplished group even before today's
commencement and this has been a highly
engaged group the executive mph program
in my experience is characterized by
groups that deeply bond and this one is
no exception I know that part of the
pain of graduation usually is just
stepping back out into the world but in
this case I've heard for many of you
that part the other part of the pain is
not being able to anticipate seeing each
other on a regular basis and that you're
already working on creating new ways to
stay connected for the rest of your
careers in your lives and I applaud you
for doing that and the rest of us need
you to be able to do that too because it
will give you much more strength and
power and the roles that you move into
in fact the class of 2013 did a unique
thing of hosting informal salons a
bi-monthly public health salon open to
other executive mph students of the past
as well as the present and where they
got together and debated and I hear
sometimes quite hotly public health
issues over food and drinks ranging from
access to medicines in Sierra Leone to
gun violence in the United States
so this is a for all of us you know part
of the magic of leadership with this
kind of breadth of thinking is your
ability to engage on issues of great
import for all of us in population level
even when it's not part of the health
system that you may be leading where the
health care you may be managing so today
is a chance to really honor you and to
celebrate your accomplishments and I
think there's no better way to start it
out by hearing from another exemplary
leader and so it's my honor to introduce
our speaker today Michael Dowling who is
the president and chief executive
officer of the North shore-lij health
system this is a health system which as
you all know is delivering world-class
clinical care throughout the New York
metropolitan area as well as supporting
pioneering research at the Feinstein
institute for medical research and I
think quite innovative approaches to
medical education in the Hofstra north
shore-lij School of Medicine Michael
Dowling is really I think health systems
the executives executive in a lot of
ways he has a long career and an
exemplary one starting prior to becoming
president and CEO in 2002 he was the
health systems executive vice president
and chief operating officer and even
before that he was the senior vice
president at empire bluecross blueshield
and even before that he served in new
york state government for 12 years
including seven years as the state
director of health education and human
services and deputy secretary to the
governor he's also served as
commissioner of New York State
Department of Social Services and prior
to that
as an academic was Professor social
policy and assistant dean at the Fordham
University Graduate School of Social
Services the breadth of that experience
I think underpins some of the much of
the exemplary leadership that he has
really executed as the president and CEO
of North shore-lij health system mr.
Dowling has been honored for his
accomplishments in many ways ranging
from most recently the 2012 b'nai brith
national health care award and the gale
warden leadership excellence award from
the national center for health care
leadership to too numerous to count
awards which he told me I can't go near
except that I will mention that he
received the gold medal from the
american irish historical society and in
a moment you'll find out some of his
qualifications for that but not all mr.
dowling is a member of the Institute of
Medicine of the National Academy of
Sciences as well as serving as the board
member of the Institute for Healthcare
Improvement and the penny was the past
chair and current board member of the
national center for health care
leadership I am very honored on behalf
of all of us Michael that you're here
today and we welcome you to the podium
thank you
thank you very very much I am delighted
to be here and I first of all want to
say congratulations to all of the
graduates and I can say that even though
that Linda mentioned that your average
age was 44 from up here you all look a
lot younger so probably the oldest
person claps right and also wanna say
special thanks as you already indicated
to all the family members and friends
because nobody in any endeavor does
anything alone which is also a lesson in
leadership that whatever your endeavors
are you are always helped by a multitude
of other people some of which you don't
even know but we are the result of the
interplay of all of the relationships
that develop we develop over the course
of a career or a lifetime so I've been
as they make a few comments and they'll
be brief because I do know that there is
a reception waiting for everybody in the
back and obviously you need to get along
to have some celebrations with your
family members and friends so i'll try
to be very very brief because as you
know when you talk about anything to do
with health care you can talk for an
awful long time and you can take any sim
simple topic well again there are no
simple topics but you can take any small
topic and you can expand it and deal
with it for well over an hour that's not
what i'm going to do here so i want to
make a few comments though one is and it
is important I think for new graduates
of very accomplished individuals because
you've gone through this scenario many
times before with all of the degrees
that you have in your background and
quite frankly I'm also delighted to see
that there are so many physicians in the
group because if there is one thing that
is needed more and more and more and
more in the future than ever before in
the past is physician leadership and
I'll come back to that point in a little
while but despite the prospective of
Manny and
despite all of the confusion and all of
the complexity and the avalanche of
negativity that you often see around you
when it comes to health care it is very
very important to put all of that aside
and in my view we're living in an
extraordinary exciting time this is a
very transformational time in the field
of healthcare and we should take
advantage of it and I have happened to
subscribe to a statement by John garner
who basically said that what we have
before us are breathtaking opportunities
disguised as unsolvable problems which
is what thinking about because sometimes
we find too much we complain too much we
wonder about what can happen we doubt
ourselves with not we're afraid to take
some risk but I think the opportunity is
over the next number of years despite
all the complexity in all the confusion
as I said and in my regard to some
extent the over micromanagement by
government and a multiplicity of
regulations it is in fact a very
exciting time but to take advantage of
the opportunity there are a couple of
things I think that we have to
understand I am sure all of you know
this but let me repeat them the first
thing is that we have to recognize that
there are a lot lots of great things are
currently occurring in healthcare that
in many circumstances we suffer from the
crisis of success not failure there are
wonderful things going on each and
everyday miracles occur lives of saved
families are brought back together and
we should sit back ever so often and say
well yes we have lots of things we need
to fix but there are a lot of good
things that are going on as well because
the cop is always half full not always
half empty and I think it is very very
important for people who get into
leadership positions to not only talk
about what's not going well pretty
equally talk about all of the things
that are going well so well
the second point is that we are not
alone in terms of the transformation
that's going on all you have to do is
look around you and understand that
every industry that you're aware of is
going through major major transformation
there is a tendency in healthcare
sometimes and I'm at too many meetings
where this perspective is displayed
where it is like why would it be
happening to us look at all of the
changes and all of the things that we
now have to do and it looks like that
there is a where there's a target on our
backs but look around at every industry
there is not an industry right now that
is going to go not going through massive
transformation think of the publishing
industry think of the banking industry I
drove near where I live on the corner I
used to often stop in and get a video at
blockbuster not too long ago today where
is black blockbuster it's gone so we're
not alone here transformation is all
around us and we can learn from the
transformation that's going on and
others even though it's not in health
care we can learn from the not from the
industries that are not healthier which
we spend a lot of time doing and I
personally spend a lot of time doing the
other point is as we move into the
future as you I'm sure have been told
about by your faculty and your
leadership at the school here is that we
have to embrace a whole new business
model over the next number of years we
shall have some of the following
characteristics many more than the ones
I'm just going to mention one is the
dramatic movement from inpatient to
outpatient an ambulatory the shift from
episodic care to population health as
was mentioned earlier which by the way
is a major major major change and
anybody think we know how to do
fee-for-service medicine pretty well we
don't know yet how to do population
health medicine
as well as we should but that requires a
whole different delivery system a total
modification in the way we look at
everything a change in the way we train
staff the way in doubt the way we
recruit staff and who we recruit the way
we train staff at all levels and the
business aspects that we have to deal
with and I use the word business because
quite frankly when you're dealing with
revenue and expenses you're dealing with
a business so you cannot assume that
just because you can do good without
having without having strong business
principles you have to have strong
business principles to be able to allow
you to do good because without the
resources you can't do it and of course
we're moving into the business of risk
where we will be responsible for our
population rather than getting paid for
every time somebody comes to us for some
kind of procedure or some kind of
involvement and in our organization we
have now over the last couple of months
we have developed and built all the
competencies of an insurance company to
be fully equipped to take full risk
which we're doing right now with every
pair and it's a dramatic dramatic
cultural change not an easy change a
major cultural change the third point I
want to make is that and people don't
like this word what I like it
consumerism has arrived it's what the
consumer wants consumer / patient wants
in the future that matters not just what
we want to provide that matters health
care is very good at giving people what
we like to give them rather than giving
them what they want so we have to be
dealing with much more we're dealing
with a much more demanding populace much
more educated population for the most
part new methods new conveniences new
service we have to be very very focused
on the service by aspects of care not
just on purely the medical aspects of
care and the other point to other ones
one is the secrecy is out and
transparency is in everything is public
we've lived in a world of secrecy
we've always declared we did well
because we wrote the press releases so
we tell you how good we are but we don't
have to prove how good we are we're
moving into waddle when we'll have to
display that we're going to be good and
this is our results in quality in cost
in efficiency and I can tell you that
many of the places and many of the
entities and organizations that
currently put themselves up as the best
because it is primarily based on
reputation not outcomes when everything
is completely transparent the whole
world is going to shift when the
transparency movement which is catching
on fully catches on the last point and
at the moment is that we are moving into
the health business not just the medical
care business and I am sure and I know
for sure because i know some of the
faculty that are sitting up here that
they have been talking to you about this
we have been in the illness business not
in the health business even though we
call ourselves health organizations and
we call ourselves health promotion help
the professionals we have been in the
business of treating illness not in the
business of promoting health and that's
a huge cultural shift as well so that
requires teamwork into disciplinary
training and education it requires
getting into the communities more as you
have been talked about and educated on
I'm sure and it also means talking about
lifestyle behavior social conditions and
dealing with especially for physicians
dealing with professionals that they
tend to traditionally never have dealt
with or not want to deal with for having
to deal with him in the future and the
people in this room obviously I'm sure
understand this very well because
otherwise you wouldn't be in this room
but I can tell you that if you think
that way I assume you do you do not
reflect the views of so many physicians
that I deal with every day who'd think
their sole business is sitting in the
office dealing purely with the medical
aspects not at all dealing with the
health aspects that is something that
you can bring to the table
and that you can have a major major role
in promoting so to succeed in all of
this and to deal with these changes and
many many others that I could spend a
lot of time talking about which I want
it requires obviously leadership and to
me leadership is very different than
management leadership to me is about
embracing change is about not being
hostage to precedent it's about taking
the long view it's about thinking of
where you need to be and what you want
to be and where your organization should
be five years from now not just three
months from now not next week that's not
unimportant but you got to be thinking
about the long view because otherwise
you will never take the risks to get
there it's about being able to inspire
an influence it's about interpersonal
relationships it's about being able to
build teams it's about having been
perpetually optimistic believing that
things can always happen it's like as
Disney said if you believe it you can
make it happen it's about never on the
rest amazing what can be accomplished
and it's about breaking down silos one
of the more biggest challenges that we
have in health care today is in my view
is the inability to consistently break
down the silos that we've all been
trained in as education trains in silos
the waddle the practice doesn't deal in
silos anymore especially if you want to
promote health and we also leadership
also has to understand that reform and
especially in the environment that we're
currently in that reform is a lot lot
more than passing a piece of legislation
however good the legislation may be and
by the way there's no perfect
legislation because it's impossible to
create it because of the political
dynamics and even if you didn't have
those it would be probably impossible
anyway but reform is much more than
legislation is much more than the
Affordable Care Act nobody knows yet how
much of that will work how well it will
work it sets in place some of the ideas
that you can take and evolve into doing
it somewhat differently than the way
people the regulators would like
to do it and if people have the ability
and willing to take the risks of doing
something differently then I think that
there can be some success and it's also
leadership also means doing something
before you're told that you have to do
it I've always been terribly confused
and frustrated by the idea that in the
environment we've been in all these
years that health care professionals had
to be mandated to large extent to
promote transparency to promote
interdisciplinary training to promote
teamwork to make their quality metrics
public that should never be where we are
we should be doing that not all those
telling us to do it so we've got to be
doing things before we are either
mandated regulated at all to do it
because once you get the regulatory is
involved bodies involved and it confuses
things enormously as you aren't sure
very well know and last point is that
and it is something that I say
consistently to all new employees I meet
every new employee who is comes to our
organization and we typically higher
about 125 people a week so I meet them
all every Monday morning and have been
doing it every monday for ten years and
I tell them that they do not have jobs
they have obligations and
responsibilities and I know you
understand this but it's important to
make sure lots of other people on the
standard that we have an obligation and
a responsibility to make a distinctive
difference not just to have a title not
just to get Awards not just to stand at
the head of the table most of the people
who do that are not the real leaders
so you have the obligation to make a
distinctive difference and to understand
that the essence of leadership is about
managing the present selectively
forgetting the past selectively
forgetting the past one of the hardest
things for people to do and creating the
future thank you very very much
thank you so much Michael it's my
pleasure and privilege to introduce the
class speaker who this year is Monica
maida and I just want to say a few words
about Monica I like to start off by
saying it's an honor to be selected as
the class speaker because your peers
choose you and I understand there was no
11th hour negotiating that Monica were
one on an early ballot I for those of
you who don't know Monica she is a
pharmacist specializing in infectious
disease at newyork-presbyterian hospital
prior and her career she was a faculty
member in pharmacy what you may know
less about her is that she's also a
documentary filmmaker and she's
interested in making films about health
both domestic and global and all aspects
of health and I encouraged her to do
that because we need to get the word out
and the last thing I'll say is a little
bit more personal to her role in this
class and in our program she's
maintained the blog which I want to
thank her for because the blog in the
and the comments and thoughts that she's
posted and written about have been
fantastic and have supported and I think
really given so much back to the to the
program Monica thank you but even beyond
all of that I appreciate her for the
classroom presence that she brings the
commitment her leadership and discussion
her questioning and her her real
motivation to make the kind of
distinctive difference that that Michael
has talked about so well so Monica thank
you very much and I'm looking forward to
your comments
thank you very much dr. Donna and thank
you to my class for elekton me this is
the true story of 33 strangers picked to
be in a graduate program and work
together for 2400 hours over two years
and find out what happens when people
stop being polite and start getting real
all the Gen Xers in the room get the
reference I think but unlike the real
world the show we never stopped being
polite we just stopped being inhibited
and that's why the experiment worked
learning is fostered by an environment
in which one can think and speak freely
where we let the boundaries blur and
getting real is what we got throw in an
obgyn from the Bronx and you get a
conversation started if our class had a
motto it would be no more small talk top
should be big I learned many lessons
from my classmates to never be hesitant
to speak even if you're contradicting
the last thing you said never put
yourself into a box to always follow a
brilliant comment that silence is the
room with a snarky guffaw because it
makes you less intimidating invoking
Shakespeare or 80s epic movies and your
PowerPoint presentation will always
impress an audience because art in
nostalgia can drive any point home
during even the most intense of
discussions a funny email sent at the
right moment can put everyone back onto
the same side because humor is a
language that we all speak and finally
wearing cufflinks or high heels should
never stop you from dancing on the a
train
because happiness is a legitimate health
care outcome our class was very Dow both
reverent and cheeky polished and rough
candid and diplomatic now that it's over
it's very evident that our program much
like life was about the path may be more
like bumper cars than actual highway but
we trusted the people that catapulted us
now as much as we try to continue the
conversation it's time we cut the cord
no more happy hours on the roof deck of
bard Hall we're on our own now but every
new beginning is some other beginnings
end some of change jobs and trajectories
other others obviously not so but all of
us have three new additional letters on
our signature lines and with those three
letters there is an expectation that we
continue the conversation that we change
the conversation and rightly so because
it's about the destination as well it's
not just that you can comment on a
kaplan-meier curve calculate a risk
ratio or do a decision tree analysis
believe me it's cool and you can impress
people at dinner parties by explaining
the origin of the phrase a switch in
time saves nine but it's not just about
the language it's about having the
confidence to chase things that you
would otherwise run from learning can be
insidious it sneaks up on you if you ask
me to sit down and tell you every fact I
learn over the two years it would take
five minutes but you're measuring the
wrong thing it's not recall but
restructuring education changes your
interstitial fluid and when your glasses
change you look at the same thing with
more clarity and that makes all the
difference this is something that I
think it's important to acknowledge but
even more so I think it's important to
trust trust yourself to be part of the
conversation
continue to engage and ask the right
questions trust your skills to
independently evaluate policy that
affects the health of the public and to
your patients it was a great time to be
at maleman the implementation and
challenge Andrey challenge of the
Affordable Care Act lipitor went generic
the historic Supreme Court vote on the
individual mandate hospital mergers and
acquisitions like will enna NYU merry
mount sinai or will continue merry mount
sinai and then a government shutdown on
the day that health care exchanges were
launched being indifferent is not an
option not that indifference was
anything we were ever accused of though
of course we didn't start the fire even
before there was Alison Lyons ankeny and
yossi schwartz there was alexander
hamilton and george washington and
before then there was Thomas Hobbes and
John Locke or so I've heard going back
to school is no small decision ampio EMP
hrs have an incredibly busy life at
baseline adding graduate schools in the
mix requires massive personal
reorganization where a balance is ever
elusive on the outside my classmates
achieve this with grace early morning
workouts always having something smart
to say based on the hundred page reading
of a case you did the previous night but
make no mistake there is a super human
element to it but we didn't do it alone
Malcolm Gladwell wrote a book about
highly accomplished people called
outliers in an interview he said my wish
with outliers is that it makes us
understand how much of a group project
successes when outliers become outliers
is not just because of their own efforts
it's because of the contributions of
lots of different people and lots of
different circumstances
and that means that we as a society have
more control about who succeeds and how
many of us succeed than we think which
is to say that we didn't do this alone
on behalf of my classmates thank you to
our family and our friends this may be
our graduation but you inspired
encouraged and supported if we stand
tall today it's on your shoulders thank
you to our professors for changing our
perspective for inspiring us to think a
lot and differently thank you to our
program administrators for your
attention to detail and for softening
the blow and we all have one of these
thank you to the person we call two
years ago to ask I'm thinking about
going back to school should i do it am i
crazy thank you for saying yes you
should and last to my classmates be
lovers and fighters in that order and if
you disagree with anything I said let's
meet on the rooftop of bard hall or at
the salon or in cyberspace to continue
the conversation because I was just
joking about cutting the cord thank you
and I wanted to say one last thing I
wanted to say happy birthday to Salim's
father who flew here from turkey mr. ark
estoy and
and thank you and happy birthday to my
father it's his birthday as well so
thank you
good evening it is my great honor and
pleasure to call out the names of the
candidates for the degree of Master of
Public Health Dean freed it is my honor
to present to you the class of 2013
executive Master of Public Health
candidates paid on madam
salam are just saw
again young berkovich
Alan bean stock Susan bocklage trade
brown Diane come on
Ellen Coleman
carmen de Lyon
Katherine dent injure
Dave Dobbins Anthony Donatelli
Tammy Rosado Gruenberg
mazon has she show and then her shkoj
you
rashmi car
Barbara Kareem
JD Lou Allison Lions ankeny
Larry Marsh
Monica meta
Elyon Patek Schwartz
David Ramos
yossi schwartz
Teresa Espada
Stacy Stewart
Joanne sigh
I'm a twice
Joan Warner
and Brad wilkin and guests
congratulations class of 2013
congratulations again this is a very
moving occasion to mark the passage of a
great enterprise of learning mixed with
aspirations and deep values for the
future of health and healthcare in our
society and at this moment of population
health as Michael Dowling just said it I
think it is very exciting to be able to
graduate a class of leaders with such
strong grounding and the values and
goals of Public Health and so it is
fitting at this point to ask our
graduates to rise and to say with me in
a moment the public health oath an oath
written at this school which all
graduates we asked to commit to to
characterize what our mission and values
and goals are and to have a rudder to
guide you for the future so please join
me in saying the public health oath
health is a human right the public
health community exists to safeguard
that right I believe it is a defining
element of a civil society public health
represents the collective actions
necessary to protect the health of all
people through prevention science and
practice we can accomplish this goal as
a public health professional guided by
these principles I declare the following
I will work to ensure that people have
the chance to live full and productive
lives free from avoidable disease and
disability
and supported in their pursuit of
physical mental and social well-being I
will hold myself to the highest ethics
standards values and responsibilities as
I move forward the science and practice
of Public Health I will respect the
rights values beliefs and cultures of
those individuals and communities with
whom I work I will rely on evidence to
support my decisions and actions and
translate that evidence into policies
and programs that improve health for all
I will add to the body of research and
knowledge and share my discoveries
freely I will continuously seek new
information and be open to ideas that
can better protect and promote the
health of populations I will advance
health literacy for all and seek equity
and justice for vulnerable populations
with this oath I commit to the ideals
and mission of Public Health
congratulations graduates
you may be seated and it is my honor to
give the last word as is fitting to
Professor Michael spare
hi thanks actually hearing someone
Monica talk about Locke and Hobbes and
Jefferson and Hamilton it it almost
makes me think I should give a lecture
but I'm not going to do that I'm not
going to do that instead I'm going to
have two very simple tasks that I want
to accomplish in the next minute or so
first just a bunch of thank yous lots
and lots of thank yous I think you've
thanked your family and your friends
appropriately I think Rebecca sale and
Carrie and Paul and Rachel and Marnie
and sort of the staff and the crew that
really runs the show really
and then looking here at the podium Dean
freed and Dean delva and the faculty you
know with tremendous support I think
from the dean's office and from the
faculty so I really just want to thank
them as well
Michael darling that was a truly
inspirational speech that I think we all
enjoyed and learned a lot comes I want
to thank you and then I just want to
also say thank you to the the class
itself class of 2013 I've been teaching
in the exact program for a long time
longer than I that I want to say at this
point but but watching you listening to
you being in the classroom with you
reminds me of why I so so so enjoy
working with exec mph students and
you're among the best of the best of
that group it's just been a real
pleasure for me and honor for me to get
to know you as students and colleagues
and and now friends and I really hope we
can continue that so thank you and then
the very last thing I want to say is
that while you've all been looking up
here at me behind you the little white
tablecloths are coming off some of those
tables there and one thing that I think
we all can say and one thing that I
think we all sore and got a sense of in
terms of your spirit atau is that this
is a class that likes to party and I
think we're going to do our best to get
the party started there a song and it
goes like that let's get this place but
let's now get this party started
congratulations class of 13 there's a
reception right behind you
and we gone away
you